Frozen was a sensation when it hit theaters
in 2013.
The tale of two sisters trapped in a perpetual
winter was an awards season darling and a
major box-office smash.
Now, the highly-anticipated sequel is expected
to hit theaters on November 27th, 2019.
Disney is tight-lipped on details, but some
juicy tidbits have managed to slip through
the icy cracks.
Here are all the Frozen 2 rumors and spoilers
so far.
Together again
It wouldn't be Frozen without Princess Elsa
and Princess Anna.
The vocal talent behind both royals, Idina
Menzel and Kristen Bell, are returning for
the sequel.
They've even recorded many of their lines
already.
Anna's love interest Kristoff is also back
in business, with Jonathan Groff confirming
he's returned to the recording studio.
The wacky snowman Olaf, a fan favorite voiced
by Josh Gad, will be on hand, too.
Alan Tudyk, who voiced The Duke of Weselton
in the original film, is coming back in a
big way.
A staple of Disney and Pixar films, Tudyk
previously lent his vocal stylings to films
like Wreck It Ralph, Moana, and Zootopia.
He told SlashFilm he's coming back, but isn't
sure what character he'll be playing.
That answer sounds… rather weaselly.
"Weselton!
It's Weselton!"
A girlfriend for Elsa?
Some fans have campaigned for the sequel to
include a female love interest for Elsa.
Co-director and screenwriter Jennifer Lee
gave those fans some hope by telling The Huffington
Post,
"[There have been] tons of conversations about
it.
[…] We'll see where we go."
While appearing on The Tyler Oakley Show,
actress Idina Menzel even had some ideas about
who Elsa's love interest might be:
"You can't help who you have a connection
with."
"Tinkerbell?
Hahahaha."
"Tinkerbell, that's cute."
The sisters: A deeper look
To prepare for the sequel, Jennifer Lee sat
down and wrote journal entries as both sisters.
She even had a psychologist psychoanalyze
Anna and Elsa while conceiving the Broadway
musical version of Frozen, so she must have
the answers to some burning, or freezing,
questions:
"What did I ever do to you?"
"Enough, Anna."
"No!
Why, why do you shut me out?
Why do you shut the world out?"
Songwriter Kristen Anderson-Lopez says many
of these revelations will be reflected in
the new music, too.
She tells Variety:
"We know the girls a lot better now.
We've gone a lot deeper into their heads."
The parents are back… somehow
Anderson-Lopez also claims the filmmakers
got to know Elsa and Anna's parents a lot
better in the process of writing the next
movie.
That means the sequel may explore why the
parents locked Elsa away, causing the deep
rift between the two sisters.
One of the more outlandish rumors suggests
we'll get to know the parents better.. .because
they aren't really dead.
Some unsubstantiated reports suggest they
might not have died in that shipwreck, although
it's more likely that we'll learn more about
the parents through flashbacks or through
memories from Anna and Elsa.
Elsa's fun side
Throughout Frozen, Elsa came to terms with
her powers and tried to figure out a way to
use them without hurting anybody.
While her journey led to lots of incredible
drama, it didn't leave much room for lighter
moments.
"How?
What power do you have to stop this winter?
To stop me…?"
That changed with the animated shorts Frozen
Fever and Olaf's Frozen Adventure, which let
Elsa show off her lighter side.
Co-director Chris Buck told Fandango he loved
making the shorts because he could have more
fun with Elsa.
He added that the sequel will go down a similar
path, saying that we'd see more of her personality
come out in the next movie.
We loved Frozen's drama, but it'll be fun
watching Elsa break the ice by cracking jokes,
too.
The hidden folk
In Frozen, Anna and Elsa encountered a group
of noble troll people who helped them understand
magic.
But the Broadway musical version of the film
dropped the troll people in favor of a new
group of characters: the hidden folk.
Well, the hidden folk may be moving from the
stage to the big screen in Frozen 2.
The show's co-songwriter Kristen Anderson-Lopez
told Variety:
"We've thought a lot more about those hidden
folk.
[...] That's all I'm going to say."
Strange Magic?
Frozen 2 has been the tentative title for
the upcoming film, but one rumor suggests
the sequel will be called Frozen: Strange
Magic.
Disney registered several domain names related
to Strange Magic, which seems to support this
theory.
The term was used in an ad for the first film,
and spoken by The Duke of Weselton:
"Strange magic has frozen this land."
"Now we just have to survive this blizzard!"
It seems likely Disney will want to use a
title that's a bit more artful than Frozen
2, and Strange Magic certainly seems apt.
Of course, we'll just have to wait and see
what the official title will be.